Of all the animals that we’ve examined in
the microcosmos, leeches are probably one
of the few that can be used as a verb.
I don’t know what it would mean to “tardigrade”
someone or something, but I do know what it
means to leech off someone—
to take and take from them, like a worm consuming
someone’s blood.
It’s funny though, isn’t it, that we use
this word in such a derogatory way?
We make an insult out of an animal we nearly
drove to extinction in some countries because
we found them so useful, you might even ask
then, are we the leech, leeching off of leeches?
Before we go too deep into sympathizing with
leeches, let’s be clear:
leeches are very creepy for most of us anyway.
James, our master of microscopes, has come
across leeches several times in his pond samples.
A few years ago, he found two finger-length
black leeches in his samples and decided to
put them in a container with the lid completely
sealed.
His professor warned him that they would escape,
but James figured he'd closed the lid
tight enough to ensure they would stay in
the container.
So he left it in the bathroom and
he went to bed.
The next morning, when he went to the bathroom,
he saw the one thing you don’t want to see
when you have a container with leeches in
your home.
The lid was on the floor, and the container
was empty.
They had somehow managed to escape, and now
James was in a home with two kittens and a
pair of wayward leeches.
He searched through everything and to his
enormous relief, he finally managed to find
the leeches behind his washing machine, covered
in dust bunnies.
But at least he did learn
to not underestimate them.
These leeches we’re looking at now are from
a different genus than his runaway pair, but
they also posed a challenge.
They were able to attach themselves to the
glass of their fish tank with so much strength
that James could not retrieve them like he
normally would.
And when they did detach themselves from the
sides of the tank, the leeches would quickly
swim down into the sediment and disappear.
Eventually, James was able to get a hold of
them.
But the struggles still continued.
The leeches were simply not content to rest
on the slides.
They would escape, they would crawl, they
would roll.
One even jumped down from the microscope!
Now James was finally able to rein them in through
a clever arrangement of slides and coverslips
that let him record them.
And we are both grateful for his persistence,
and very glad that none of us were in the
room with him and those leeches.
As we mentioned earlier, “leech” has the
distinction of referring both to an animal
and an insult inspired by said animal.
That might not be unusual when we look at
macroscopic animals, but animals of the microcosmos
are of course so small that they don’t often
get the opportunity to permeate our language
in many forms.
The use of the word “leech” to describe a person
as a parasite is only a few centuries old.
But we have a long history with the word “leech,”
going back to at least the year 900 CE.
In Old English, “leech” could mean one
of two things.
One is the blood-sucking worm that we’re
looking at right now.
The other meaning is “doctor”.
The two definitions actually came into Old
English from two different origins, but they
came to be intertwined in meaning the way
that leeches and doctors have been intertwined
in practice.
In the older understanding of medicine, built
upon the concept of humors that were transported
around the body through blood, blood-letting
was seen as a way to restore balance.
Excess blood, it was thought, could lead to
disease.
And so removing that blood could be a medical
necessity.
Of course, you could remove the blood through
surgical means.
But leeches were a nice alternative.
Slower, not quite as painful.
And there are some afflictions where a patient
might prefer a worm to a doctor stabbing them.
The main downside was the need to prevent
leeches from crawling into the patient through
their mouth, nose, or anus.
There are actually hundreds of leech species,
but the one used for medical purposes was
named Hirudo medicinalis
in 1758 by Carl Linnaeus.
In the wild, this worm feed on mammals,
fish, and amphibians, tracking movements in
the water along with heat and chemical signals
to find their host.
Then, it uses its three jaws and the
sharp teeth lining them to pierce the skin.
The leech will usually consume anywhere from 2 to
5 times their body weight in blood, relying
on a cocktail of enzymes and other molecules
in their saliva to keep the blood flowing
and not clotting.
When they’re done, the leech might take
months to digest that meal.
Around the 18th and 19th centuries, using
leeches as a medical tool ballooned in popularity,
thanks in part to the influence of the
French physician Francois-Joseph-Victor Broussais
which led to a massive trade in the worm across
Europe.
If you read about the history of leeching,
you’ll find all sorts of terrifying statistics
describing their use.
For example, in 1832, France was estimated
to have imported more than 50 million leeches.
Imagine transporting hundreds
of thousands of leeches.
Or maybe you shouldn’t imagine that.
But of course, trading leeches also meant
catching them, which is easy when you’re
the exact host that leeches are looking for.
Leech hunters would simply use their feet
as bait, extracting the worms from their own
bodies to be able to send them on their way.
And look, leeches weren’t some rare animal.
But when people began trading them in such
massive quantities, that changed.
That was a problem for trade, but also for
wild leech populations.
Some countries approached this problem by trying
to build leech farms that could reduce the
need for wild leeches.
Others tried to raise prices or limit exports,
sometimes even banning them.
But something else was changing as well.
Scientists started doubting whether leeches
were really that great of a medical tool to
begin with.
The most notable opponent was the French physician
Pierre Charles Alexandre Louis, who argued
that leeching might actually be leaving patients
in worse conditions.
And this was the century where scientists
began to consider an alternate explanation
for disease, one built not on balances of
humors, but rather on the existence of germs.
And that opened up new approaches to treatment,
one that did not rely on latching a blood-sucking
worm onto people’s skin.
So the leech trade eventually died out, but
the combination of our use of leeches and
the decline of their wetland habitat have left
its mark on the Hirudo medicinalis population.
At first, it seemed like they may have gone
extinct entirely in Western Europe, but reports
of their demise seem to have been exaggerated.
Not that the reality is that much better.
If you look up their status in various countries
in Western Europe, you’ll see every label
from not threatened to rare to extinct to
unknown.
But they have made a comeback in medicine.
Though not to the same degree that they were used
before, but Hirudo medicinalis and their close
relative Hirudo verbena are used in hospitals
for certain treatments, like draining the
clotted blood of haematomas.
And aside from their medical uses, leeches
have a well-studied system of ganglia—
the cluster of neurons that you can see here.
And that has made leeches a useful model for
scientists to use to better understand the
interplay between an animal’s nervous system
and its behavior.
So our history continues to be entwined with
the leech.
And while we started by asking whether we are
really the leech here, maybe that’s
too simple a question.
This is an animal whose life is intrinsically
connected to ours through blood, a relationship
forged through evolution and reshaped by history.
So maybe the question isn’t one we can answer,
but rather something open-ended:
if a leech has been a worm, a parasite, a
doctor, an action—
what else can it be that we don’t yet know?
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
The people whose names are on the screen right
now, they are our Patreon patrons.
The people who make it possible for us to
make this content.
And while some of them may be questioning
their decision, considering how much leech
content just got thrown at them, I think that
most of them are very satisfied with the decision.
We certainly keep our patrons for a long time
and we very much appreciate that.
If you would like to become one of our Patreon
patrons, you can join us at Patreon.com/JourneytoMicro.
If you want to see more from our Master of
Microscopes, James Weiss, because he's always
doing wonderful and amazing things, you can
check out Jam and Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, there's
always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.